it's The Suite Life of Zack & Cody the
movie yet again another movie based on a
show I didn't watch and if this movie is
any indication of what the show is like
I think it's pretty obvious why I did
watch it the suite life starts off by
Rana CLE having nothing to do with
sweets in fact it's actually on a ship
oh just assume something happen in the
show to make that happen actually it's a
little weird seeing how Zack and Cody
are technically in the title of this
movie only the sweet life is and yet
there's no suite in it so honestly this
entire movie is a complete lie
regardless Zack and Cody are identical
twins but one of them has a problem you
want an internship to get into Yale
which means he can't hang out with his
girlfriend perfect she gets pissed off
splitting up with him and to make things
worse his smart aleck brother messes up
his internship getting him thrown out
but it looks like the scientist he was
working with has another internship for
him one that involves no surprise twins
so they're both sent to this lab the
experiments on twins to see if they can
create a certain fruit where the more
you eat it the more you can feel each
other's pain grow empathy and eventually
become one mind but wait isn't that a
bad thing well yes it is when we
discover that the scientist actually has
evil plans to turn all twins into one
hive and force them to take over I don't
know the world it's kind of a weird plan
for kind of a weird movie so the biggest
problem with this film is very obvious
it's not funny but I don't think it's
supposed to be funny to me this is funny
to the same crowd that liked to say good
burger like little little kids one of
the earliest jokes they have is miss
hearing mammal for camel actually
and if you didn't laugh of that I'm
sorry that's what they think is the best
joke in fact they do it four times in
the film they're not fishies then why
don't the movie is mostly filled with
humor like this and actors that aren't
bad but are good either it's slow clunky
awkward but again I think it's that way
because it's mainly aiming for a little
little children to be watching it yeah
you might be arguing don't our little
kids deserve better and yeah sure but at
the same time there's nothing really
harmful in this I'm not watching this
think it's like camp Rock to where
there's actually a bad message or bad
ideas being thrown by maybe even once in
a while gets a little bit of a giggle
like the delivery from the mad scientist
is legitimately well-timed
yeah once in a while the girlfriends
delivery can get a feel out everything
else is just kind of what you think
would be done with this concept just
kind of slow and not funny but I'd be
lying if I said I couldn't see an
audience of little kids watching this
and having a fun time is there anything
in it for adults no is there anything
really that great for kids in it no it's
nobody season is anyone gonna miss out
on anything
probably not but nothing is gonna be
made worse by saying it either it's like
a sock puppet show there's nothing
really to it but what's there really to
get angry at either
it's hitting the right crowd and not
making anything worse I know that's
definitely not a glowing recommendation
but what can I say this movie didn't
leave that big an impact on me if you
liked it you're probably the exact right
age group for it and if you don't you're
probably the exact wrong age group for
it I guess I could be angry and say kids
deserve a lot more but honestly it's
just not worth the effort it's Zack and
Cody it's stupid but it's painless take
it for what it's worth and just be happy
it's not Cheetah Girls if you think
that's the best thing I can say about it
you're right later
you